في انتظار الرئيس الفرنسي المنتخب
ايمانويل ماكرون الذي يتاهب لتسلم سلطاته
يوم الاحد المقبل كثير من الاختبارات
العسيره بع خارجي يخص العلاقه مع العالم
العربي وتحديدا الجزائر فبينما يحتفل
الفرنسيون بانتصار الحلفاء على المانيا
النازيه هذه الايام يجتر الجزائريون
احزانا عمرها عقود مع حلول ذكرى واحده من
ابشع مجازر الاستعمار الفرنسي في بلادهم
ماكرون زار الجزائر مؤخرا خلال الحمله
الانتخابيه واسمع مضيفيه كلاما معسولا عن
ضروره اعتذار بلاده للجزائريين عن 10
عاما من الاستعمار حافله بالمجازر
والتنكيل فهل يطابق ماكرون الرئيس مواقف
ماكرون المرشح ربما لكنه في كل الاحوال لا
يستطيع الرهان على عامل الزمن فثم الام لا
يسكنها مرور
الزمن ذكرى بطعمين انتصار هنا والم هناك
على هذه الضفه من وسط تحتفل فرنسا بذكرى
الانتصار على المانيا النازيه في الحرب
العالميه الثانيه وتلك احتفالات قدر لرئيس
فرنسا الشاب المنتخب ان يشارك سلفه
الاشراف عليها قبل ان يتسلم منه رسميا
مهامه
الرئاسيه اما هناك جنوبا فتتم المستعمره
القديمه على نحو 45 الفا من شهداء اليوم
ذاته الثامن من مايو عام
45 ظن الجزائريون الذين شاركوا فرنسا
الحرب ضد دول المحور ان المستعمر سيبر
بوعده فيعيد اليهم
سيادتهم لكن كانت حمله اباده بحق المدنيين
العزل في ولايات سطيف وجال وخراطه بشرقي
الجزائر شكلت هذه واحده من جرائم فرنسا
الاستعماريه التي ما تزال الجزائر الرسميه
والشعبيه تطالب باريس بالاقرار بها
والاعتذار رسميا
عنها للجزائريين قبل ثلاثه شهور ان
ايمانويل ماكرون الذي كان مرشحا للرئاسه
في فرنسا وقت ذاك قد خطى خطوه في ذلك
الاتجاه في الجزائر التي زارها قال ان
الاستعمار الذي هو جزء من تاريخ بلده
جريمه ضد الانسانيه وعلى الفرنسيين ان
يقدموا الاعتذار لمن ارتكبت بحقهم لا
غرابه ان اثارت تصريحاته جدلا حادا في
فرنسا واستياء في صفوف اليمين واليمين
المتطرف
مع ذلك نبه البعض الى ان ماكرون المرشح
انما كان يغازل اصوات الناخبين الفرنسيين
من اصول جزائريه والان بعد ان دخل
الاليزيه ليس باصواتهم بالضروره سيتضح ما
اذا كان الرئيس مختلفا عن المرشح
للرئاسه يبدو انه سيواجه مبكرا ملف
الذاكره الذي ما يزال يعكر صفو علاقات
البلدين ويعوق
تطويرها منذ استقلال الجزائر مطلع 6 القرن
الماضي تصر باريس بيمينها ويسارها على رفض
فكره الاعتذار عن ماضيها الاستعماري في
الجزائر ربما مخافه الاضطرار لدفع تعويضات
او مواجهه القضاء الدولي فلننسى الماضي
ونلتفت الى المستقبل قالها كثيرون في
فرنسا ابرزهم نيكولا ساركوزي الذي تبنى
حزبه عام 2005 ما وصف بقانون تمجيد
الاستعمار وهو من فضل ترك المساله
للمؤرخين او رحيل جيل الثوره عن الحكم في
الجزائر وتجاه الجزائر قدم الاشتراكيون
الفرنسيون من جانبهم اشارات ايجابيه لكن
فرانسوا اولوند لم يجرؤ على طرح ما اعتبر
اعترافا رمزيا بجرائم بلده الاستعماريه
على البرلمان والان ثمت في فرنسا رئيس
جديد يوصف في الجزائر بالصديق ولا تخفي
الرئاسه الجزائريه املها في تحقيق مصالح
حقيقيه بين البلدين في عهده يعتقد محللون
ان ماكرون سيمثل امتدادا لسياسات اولان
تجاه الجزائر ربما مع غموض اقل وشراكه
اكبر لكن شيئا لن يتغير حقا دون حسم مساله
الذاكره لنقترب اكثر من ذكرى مذابح الثامن
من مايو ايار وموقعها في ماضي الجزائريين
وحاضرهم وارتباطها بالعلاقات مع فرنسا
ينضم الينا من الجزائر عبر سكايب السيد
سليمان شنين مدير مركز الرائد للدراسات
والابحاث ومن باريس باتريك
فورستي الكاتب الصحفي المختص في الشان
الافريقي مرحبا بكما سيد سليمان ماذا
تتوقع الجزائر من الرئيس المنتخب
ماكرون
نعم سيد سليمان هل تسمعني هو السقف
المطلوب من ماكرو قب بالنظر الى الموقف
الرسمي الفرنسي وبالنظر لردود الفعل
الفرنسيه من مختلف
مكونات الساحه المشهد السياسي الفرنسي بعد
تصريحاته في الجزائر في منتصف الشهر فيفري
لما زارها وتحدث عن جريمه جريمه ضد
الانسانيه في حق الجزائريين ارتكبت من من
فرنسا وبالتالي
ماكرون بوجوده دون حزب وبدون وضوح رؤيه
مستقبليه وربما تجاذبات كبرى سياسيه في
المستقبل لا يمكنه ان يراهن كثيرا على
موضوع
تصحيح الجانب التاريخي
ل ما ت كبته فرنسا باتجاه الجزائر
والجزائريين شعبيا وحتى رسميا
وحزب يطالبون
بتجريم هذا المستعمر الذي يعني تمر علينا
ذكرى 8 ماي 45 ونتكلم عن جرائم
شعبيه لمواطنين مسالمين لم يرفعوا السلاح
الا انهم طالبوا
بحقوقهم على اثر وعود فرنسيه وبالتالي كيف
يمكن لجيل 2017 ان يصدق هذه اليد الممدوده
من الفرنسيين في علاقه نديه او في علاقه
طبيعيه وهم يدركون جيدا ان التاريخ يعيد
نفسه كل مره ولهذا ربط العلاقه الجزائريه
الفرنسيه مستقبلا مربوط على الاجيال
القادمه على ان يكون موقف تاريخي لفرنسا
في الاعتراف باقل شيء بما قامت به تصريحات
ماكرون صحيح انها غير مسبوقه ولكنها لا
ترقى الى ان تكون سلوك سياسي او تترجم على
مستوى فرنسا
الرسميه على على مستوى القرارات او على
مستوى التعاطي مع الجزائر بذهن اقل شيء ما
يقال عنها بذهن ان الجزائر في 2017 هي
دوله مستقله عن فر
وتريد ان تكون لها سياده كامله وترغب ان
تكون لها علاقه متميزه مع فرنسا ولكن ضمن
السياده الوطنيه وضمن الاستقلال الك دعني
اطرح السؤال على السيد باتريك فورستي سيد
باتريك عندما تحدث السيد ماكرون المرشح عن
مذابح بلاده او عن ماضي الاستعمار الفرنسي
في الجزائر ثارت ثائره الطيف السياسي من
يمينه الى يساره على
الرجل كيف تتعايش فرنسا مع هذا الذنب الا
اذا كانت تزور تاريخها للاجيال القادمه او
تتنكر لميراث الكبير من القيم الانسانيه
والحضاريه نعم حرب الجزائر مازالت حاضره
بقوه في فرنسا كما هو شان في الجزائر
عندما
يقولان
ماكرون بان ما حث في الجزائر هو يرقى الى
الجريمه ضد الانسانيه خلال شهر فبراير
الماضي عندما زار الجزائر
نعم
هناك خلفيه سياسيه لان لدينا حوالي 30 الف
فرنسي يصوتون في الجزائر وهناك
ايضا جاليه جزائريه كبيره في فرنسا وهي
قوه انتخابيه تصل الى حوالي مليون
ونصف على الاقل وهناك الكثير من
الجزائريين الذين يحملون الجنس الفرنسيه
اذا هناك بالتاكيد او كان هناك بالتاكيد
مقاربه سياسيه فيما تحدث وفيما تفضل به
ماكرون عندما كان مرشحا وكان حرا بالحديث
عن اي شيء وكان يتحدث بصفته الشخصيه وليس
باسم الدوله الفرنسيه اليوم اصبح رئيسا لا
اعتقد انه سيستمر في نفس السياق ولن
يتحدث المقاط اسالك اسالك عن هذا عرا على
المقاطعه
سيخ سيد باترك عذرا على المقاطعه اسالك عن
هذا تحديدا كيف تتعايش فرنسا مع هذا
الماضي الاليم دون ما حتى تقديم كلمه
اعتذار للضحايا
بهذه الصوره تقول انه كان حرا عندما كان
مرشحا والان اصبح يتحدث باسم الدوله
الفرنسيه انا اسال عن الدوله الفرنسيه
ذاتها كيف يمكن ان تتعايش مع هذا الذنب
العظيم الا اذا كان الامر فقط يتعلق
بمساله الخوف من التعويضات الماليه
والملاحقات القانونيه وسحقا بعد ذلك على
المبادئ والقيم الفرنسيه التي تتغنى بها
باريس ليل
نهار قبل تقديم الاعتدار يجب ان تقوم
العداله الدوليه باثبات الجريمه يجب ان
تاخذ الامور مسارها القانوني يجب ان يكون
مفهوم الجريمه ثابتا ويجب ان تفصل محكمه
دوليه في هذا النزاع ويجب ان يصدر حكم في
هذا الصدد لذلك بعد ذلك يمكننا ان نتحدث
عن
تعويضات الان لا يمكننا ان
نتحدث هذا على السيد سليمان من الجزائر
سيد سليمان هل قصرت الحكومات الجزائريه
المتعاقبه في توثيق ما جرى في الجزائر من
مذابح على يد الاستعمار الفرنسي ومع هذا
التطور القانوني الدولي والمحاكم المختصه
في التصدي لمثل هذه القضايا هل ليست هناك
لدى الجزائر قضيه متكامله الاركان ثابته
يمكن من خلالها ان تقاضي فرنسا للاسف
الشديد الاراده السياسيه في الجزائر غير
متوفره في تجريم المستعمل فرنسي في
2005 تقدم نواب من الحزب الحاكم من جبهه
التحرير الوطني بقانون مشروع قانون في
للمجلس الوطني الشعبي لتجريم الاستعمار
ولكنه قوبل بالرفض من السلطات الرسميه في
البلد ووضع هذا القانون في في الادراج هذ
هذا الذي يطرح اشكال كبير عند الراي العام
الجزائري يعني كيف تقعون اذاء هذا الوضع
سيد سيد سليمان كيف تتوقعون من الفرنسيين
ان يتطوعوا للاعتذار اذا كانت الاراده
السياسيه لدى الضحيه غائبه اصلا اعتقد
انه الاداره او الحكومات والسلطه
الجزائريه تتكلم خارج يعني خارج بدون
العلن تحت في الغرف المغلقه مع الفرنسيين
تطالبهم بهذا دون احراج لنتيجه ان الوضع
الدولي والجو سياسي للمنطقه وفرنسا تعتبر
الوكيل الحصري لشمال افريقيا دوليا ترغب
منها ان تقدم خطوات اتجاه ارضاء او
استرضاء الراي العام دون احراج كبير لها
وتحاول ان تجد تجد تفاهمات بعيد عن عن
الاحراجات الكبرى ولكن الراي العام
والشباب الجزائري الحالي والقوى الوطنيه
والاسلاميه لا تتقبل مثل هذا الموقف وتريد
من السلطه الجزائ من السلطات الجزائريه ان
يكون موقفها واضحا وان تكون الاراده
السياسيه واضحه في المطالبه والتوثيق
موجود بالمناسبه اما جزائريا او او فرنسيا
صحيح اننا لازلنا نعاني من مشكله الارشيف
والفرنسيين ليس فقط قتلوا وذبحوا وا بل
ارادوا كذلك ان يحتفظوا بكل ما له صله
بهذا التارخ جزي سليمان شنين مدير مركز
الرائد للدراسات والابحاث كان معنا عبر
سكايب من الجزائر واشكر ضيفنا من باريس
باتريك فورست الكاتب الصحفي المختص في
الشان
الافريقي نهايه الحصاد الى اللقاء
[موسيقى]
ان